Welcome to tea time with sarnie I'm Amanda Cerny.
And this is where I play tennis with some of my friends and have a little Q and
a session while we play. But today's special guest is going to be a Roche.
Oh my gosh. And Elia is super famous.
How many campaigns to campaign? Well, a lie of the tater top.
Follow her. She's so freaking cute. This is distracting.
I feel like this is a method for you to 100%. That's why she's here.
She's here for me to take the w R have you played tennis before?
I have, but I'm not really good at it. All right. Well, let's just play ball.
Wait. That's baseball. Oh, okay.
Oh, Oh my God. Welcome ladies. Um,
I don't okay, here we go. Um, wow, you are adorable.
You guys ready to play? Sorry. Distracted, distracted. Um, who is,
what do you think? Heads or tails? Heads. Heads. Yeah. Okay.
You, you achieve.
I think that's a tale.
It was, it was heads. It was a hundred percent heads.
So you'll pick who serves first. I'll let her Madison, okay. Amanda.
Oh, wait. I know. I'm like, wait, here you go.
All right. Love all
first question is how did you get started with, um,
beauty and makeup and all that good stuff? I used to do it on myself.
You used to do it on yourself? Yeah. I used to Dan,
so I had to do stage makeup on myself since I was five,
but I started when I was 17 and I would do everyone's makeup for $45
in my bedroom. Yup. That's so cool. You're a little hustler. I know.
Right? Making that money, honey, from an early age. Love it.
You still haven't done my makeup. That was out
going go into box. Are you sure? Yep.
Well, I don't know. Maybe you're right. Pretty sure it was in though.
I'm pretty sure. Totally out
to try to hit inside the boxes. Second, serve second serve. Yep.
You still haven't my makeup yet. One day, we're going to glam one day.
You're going to make me pound man.
30. Love.
Going to be my friend anymore after this.
Who's your favorite client? That's hard.
Oh, it was out. That one was out. Oh,
that was out. Okay. Now are we done?
Not yet. My favorite class, I feel like my muse right now has to be Chloe,
Chloe. I just really like it.
This is not cool.
40. Love.
You set all this up right? For you to play everyone so I can look good.
Playing all my friends.
How do I talk and hit it at the same time on the side.
You just had your, your birthday recently too, huh? Yeah. And you went to.
Sorry.
Can you speak Spanish? No, no apply spaniel.
Can you speak any other languages? I can speak Armenian.
Speak to me in Armenian Haydn. Wholesome
second serve. What did you say? I said,
do you speak Armenian hide and wholesomeness.
If I say hi I'm yes. You say IO. IO.
Highest IO. That's all I need to know. Yeah.
Right here. Oh, the size. How often?
So your whole family is from Armenia? Yes.
How often do you go there? Oh,
that was good, right? Yeah. I put my heart into it.
So do they all live in the U S now, are they still live there? Um,
my mom's side lives in Armenia and Russia. Yeah. My dad's side lives here.
Oh cool. But I was born in Armenia
when it was a communist.
I think I'm winning numbers. But how
What's one mistake that I always make with my makeup that you notice.
Advantage. Amanda, I feel.
Like you don't need makeup. You're so beautiful. Oh, you are. Thank you.
But you can be honest. The lashes.
Yeah. Yeah. So what do I need to do? You just need to stick it on. Oh,
is the offering? No, like stick it on fully. Oh,
I kind of dangle sometimes, but sometimes, but I feel like everyone's does.
Oh, it's out.
No.
Those were the hardest for me to figure out.
We need to do it. The toric I'll show you the easiest way to do it. Please.
What's the trick to it.
You have to place it in the center bef like when it's like tacky.
Not when it's wet. Oh. And then you have to do the outer edge.
Yeah. And then the inner corner. I don't do that.
Yeah. Noted.
Ah, Amanda.
But I have a pretty good background. No,
you're you're actually doing great hitting it like this.
I feel like I'm hitting it like this. My backhand sucks. My everything sucks.
No, I have a main backend. That's good. I'll know. Not,
not to hit it that way now. So how did you start doing, um,
the makeup for the Kardashians? It's been,
I could say like four years and I feel
like it's changed my life in many ways. Yeah.
Like mindset. So wait, I from here, I sat there.
Yes. From here over there. Yeah. Very good.
I don't know what you're talking about. Oh, she gets the point.
You got a puppy point. That's right. Elia.
You keep sticking that tongue out and swinging.
Those guys have looking cute talking to me.
So how did it change your life?
I feel like their perspective and like business.
Yeah.
Oh, very nice.
He got me on the backend,
like in business and just
all come on. Now. That was out. That was out out.
Oh, that was out.
40 Love.
Have you had your eyes checked recently? All right,
here we go.
If you say that's it I'm like, where did it go?
So what are they like?
What's one of the best things that learned about business from them.
You have to be so persistent. Never take no for an answer. It's true.
Wake up super early grind, Tilly,
sleep and Delmar ever. Yeah. You know,
that's true. And they all work so hard.
So seeing that you want to work hard too.
People don't know that.
40, 30. That's true.
People think it's so easy for them. A lot of the time. I agree.
But I feel like people don't see how much they work. Yeah.
From like their eyes, opening eyes, closing, it's all work.
And they do so much charity.
I feel like it's kind of corny to like display what you're
doing and they don't. Yeah.
I feel like they definitely deserve a lot more credit in that Avenue.
I hear through like, outside people of the,
like the stuff that they're working on and the stuff that they do. Um,
I love it.
What can do with like the plastic?
Yeah. I mean plastic bottles for the water and the ocean.
Like it's just so much stuff.
Like they promote a tiny bit just to create awareness,
but like not to gain like today they're doing a poker tournament.
Yeah. For city of help. Oh, I know. Did you hear about him? No.
I need to learn how to play poker. I need to learn to play tennis, bro.
Are you a good poker player.
Advantage?
Hmm.
I think you harness and you should get married like next week. What
do you mean too soon? No, I really, really like,
I have to ask to move into the house.
We have to get a dog that this is process life.
You shouldn't be that immediate with it because you'd be like, ah,
we have time.
This is true. Life is way too short to plan.
Why do you think Yohanis is good for me?
I go over.
What's your answer? That decides what happens with that point.
Huh? What's your answer?
Oh, why do I think Johan is that? He's a good guy. Look at him.
Taking care of him.
That's a game point right there. Yep. That was it.
Like where are you going to find the guy like this?
I feel like you guys have a side deal going this whole game.
You compliment your harness. Your harness gets to play with your dog.
I think you're getting very paranoid at this point. Maybe the sun's getting too.
You should have wore a hat for a while.
See what we're doing here we one, huh? Yeah.
We both won one round camp.
That was a really good answer. He's a good guy.
What's your favorite trend? So far, 2018.
My favorite trend. Yeah.
That one was out. Love 15.
Suck it easy. How does it taste? Let's go. Come on.
That was really out. Yeah. Oh, I served. Yeah.
She's all like messing me up. Did you undermine me booboo?
Well, I didn't. You're adding new rules to tennis here.
So what's your favorite trend?
I feel like my trend right now is that I'm into is how
everyone's being a little bit more raw.
30.
Native cheer. Well,
is that like how everyone's just being unfiltered on social media.
I do love that. Oh, it's out.
Yeah. I was out anyways. Otherwise I just going to play it.
Love 40.
I think you're hypnotized.
You're just full of distractions right now and I liked them.
I'm not mad at the distractions.
Second, sir.
Who's your favorite person to follow on social media? You ah,
I like it. Why?
What is.
Which side?
Which side am I throwing over here? Chap.
Woo.
Why me? Because you're funny as. Hey,
love.
15.
And I like to laugh. That's true. You do? Yeah.
Let's tell the story of how we met.
We met in Miami. You were with,
uh, with Jonathan, Jonathan? Yeah. Yeah. And um,
uh, something crap. Uh, Joe's
out. I think it's the Wyndham catchy.
And then we just partied in Miami for love at first sight with us.
It and it still is.
What did I teach you to do? Oh,
you taught me how to cover up at the restaurant. Aside from that,
I have a question who's serving. She is. Why did you serve right now?
Oh, okay. You serve point
besides that? Um,
what did you teach me? I don't know. Tell me
regarding what? Oh,
What did he teach me?
Oh my God. Yes.
He taught me how to make it rain. Yup.
We went to club 11 and there's this like a unique nightlife
experience. Yeah. And there's like, you know,
a certain way to throw things. Yes. It's like a technique.
Yeah. Yeah. She was teaching me how to make a mess. Surfing.
Surfing. Yeah.
And honestly I needed that because ah.
Game Amanda, last one, ladies.
I'm serving or you're serving. I'm serving. Okay. Yeah.
That was a much needed thing to know though.
Cause I've embarrassed myself so many times. I mean,
I don't really go to strip clubs often. No, when you go,
you're like I'm King. I walk in there.
It's making it rain on everybody. I'm going to get you.
I should have got you a gun. Oh, that sprays out. Confederation.
My gift to you. I'm dead. Do you have one already? I bet you do,
but you could never have. Oh, come on.
You can never have enough of those. That's true. I like to hold. Like,
I'm going to learn how to do it with my toes too. On that.
That'll be my birthday gift to you is another gun.
You got me a birthday gets with his hair. Perfume. And I love it.
You're going to love that. You're going to, this is see,
like he's going to really like me and I'm going to really like future.
You're just giving points. Yeah. Puppy points or whatever you want to call it.
Come on. I hate that. Backhand
30 love. I did not wear the appropriate attire for this game.
We got boom, swine. Everywhere. You look good though.
Thanks babe. If you're going to lose, you might as well look. Good.
40 Love. How many points does she have on me? It's one more.
If she gets one more it's over.
Okay. And how many do I need to win her
up? Five points that I'll lose. And grace,
there's still a chance. Elia. Come down. Come on, come on. Go
go. You can serve. Come on. Okay.
Imagine I just not, Oh, here we go.
Come, come here. Come here. She's the love with Yohanas.
She is second serve.
We're just still playing with it.
I guess 40 15. Whoo.
I did that on purpose because I'm over this heat.
Oh, well congratulations. I'm sorry. You lost me,
but I hyped you up. So I'm sorry. I know you lost me. My dog. So you lost a dog,
my dog, a lie.
And I actually have a little surprise for you
because you lost and you were such a good sport. You and you.
I was going to lose. That's why you asked me to play tennis. Yeah, I did.
But I got you a very special gifts. What is it? That's set out here.
So look, I'm about to fail me too. I'm actually really tired. I need like a,
a juice or something. Since you did such a good job of playing.
I got you. I know makeups your thing, some new foundation for you,
for you and um, a shower cap.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Jeez, Hollywood.
Thank you guys for watching and make sure you like subscribe.
Turn on the notifications. Check out her Rouge, check out her puppies page too.
I love her so much and I actually haven't seen you in forever. So this is fun.
And let me know in the comments, you guys who you want to see me play next.
I don't know why that's such a hard line for me, but it is love you.
See you guys later. Good job.
Hey, that's that?
They sent me so much foundation and that's the one I couldn't use
that is now yours to use as contour.
It's a compliment really? Because I wish I could be that tan.